je vais bien j'ai voilà je je suis en
état aujourd'hui de reprendre les
activités
j'ai été je le souhaite perçu comme tel
transparent sur le fait que j'avais un
cancer
je veux pas employer des termes pour
dire j'ai vaincu etc
je veux dire que merci à tous ceux qui
m'ont soutenu aujourd'hui je suis en
état de retravailler et heureux de le
faire donc je vais bien pourquoi cette
volonté de transparence ce que c'est
plutôt rare ce que je devais ça tous les
cas à mes élus et surtout aux habitants
de dijon ils me connaissent ils me
voient tout le temps j'habite c'est ma
ville de coeur
ça fait presque vingt ans je veux pas le
dire ça fait presque un an que j'en suis
une mère donc j'ai quitté mes fonctions
ministérielles pour revenir à la mairie
et donc j'ai senti un formidable besoin
de transparence qui s'est traduit par un
formidable mouvement de soutien qui m'a
beaucoup aidé dans la lutte contre le
cancer
comment vous vous projetez à dijon je
suis le maire je suis président de la
métropole il ya du travail il ya du
travail
j'ai une première adjointe qui m'a
remplacé
pendant ma ma la lutte contre la maladie
et donc elle a fait très bien donc je
suis content de voir que des gens sont
aptes le moment venu sûrement à prendre
la succession
le moment n'est pas encore venu je suis
le maire et je reste la mer